Speaker 1: Well, we have to start today with the
little red wave that couldn't. What was that kid
story? The little engine that could. This was
very much the opposite. This ended up being the
little red wave that was a ripple so small that
Democrats may actually gain seats in the Senate.
Democrats have won the Senate. Yes. We do not yet
know the results of the House. We're going to talk
on the bonus show about the specific scenarios
that could end up prevailing in the House. But
over in the Senate, it is over in the sense that
Democrats have indeed secured a majority. The
question now becomes, is it a 5050 majority with
Kamala Harris as the tie breaking vote, or is it
a 5149 majority, which would be very important.
If we want to make Joe Manchin irrelevant and we
are going to get to that. But the final numbers in
the Nevada Senate race coming in over the weekend,
as well as the calling of the Arizona race. And
this is how Democrats got to 50. Mark Kelly did
defeat Blake Masters in Arizona. There is still 6%
of the vote to be counted there. But with Kelly's
lead of over 125,000 votes, it has been called.
This is really great news for the country when
it comes to being marginally less humiliated on an
international stage. Blake Masters, the challenger
to Mark Kelly, the man who won the Republican
primary, an absolute humiliation, just a pathetic,
embarrassing, horrible can that it didn't make any
sense from the extreme MAGA wing. Almost as bad as
Kerry Flake, quite frankly. And we'll get to Kerry
Lake. Don't worry. We have plenty on Kerry Lake
coming up a little bit later. That was number 49
we have in Georgia, as we will talk about Raphael
Warnock and Herschel Walker. December 6th, there
will be a runoff. Much of our focus and attention
and resources are going to go there. And number
50, indeed, from the state of Nevada, where Cortez
Masto, the Democratic incumbent, has come out
ahead of challenger Adam Laxalt. It is a 6500 vote
lead with 98% in, it has been called. There is not
a 50% rule in the state of Nevada. Remember that
in Georgia there is a runoff because of Georgia
law that says the winner must get 50% of the vote.
In Nevada, there is no such law. And with 48.8% of
the vote, Cortez Masto is number 50 and Democrats
have won the Senate. Now there is going to be all
sorts of, after the fact, armchair quarterbacking,
prognostication, re prognostication, whatever
the case may be. A couple of storylines that
are coming up and some of them I've dealt with
myself on Twitter, which, by the way, is barely
functional anymore under Elon Musk Twit. Twitter
is, quite frankly, a disaster at this point. Let's
put that aside. Some of you coming forward and
saying even to me, sir, you were wrong about the
coming red wave. You were. You need to apologize.
As usual, some in my audience obsessed with me,
even though I have nothing to do with this. Let's
review what had been my message in the last 3 to
4 weeks. Going into this election, I told you
the momentum has shifted in the direction of
Republicans. The momentum has shifted.
That being said, many individual races,
when you look at their average polling, have a
bunch of right leaning polls included in them. And
it is making me and others suspect that some of
these forecasts, which include these right leaning
polls, may overstate the degree of momentum in the
direction of Republicans. And in the last week,
I very specifically said, whatever is the truth
about these polls, it's over. The polls are a tool
earlier on to give us a sense of the direction
in momentum when we are seven, five, three,
one day away from the election, if the polls are
right or the polls are wrong, we have to go and
vote. And thanks to a lot of 18 to 20 or 29 year
olds, which we will talk about a little bit later,
the red wave was at most a red ripple. We
will see what happens in the house very,
very soon. But Democrats will control
the Senate. Now the question is 50 or 51.